What’s up guys, my name is Colin McNeil for theScore esports.
Last week we brought you the Top 10 One Taps in CS:GO.
Now that included rifle one taps, and one deags.
But you guys let us know in the comment section that we should do an entire list devoted to just one deags.
Well you asked, and we delivered. Before we get into it though,
I'm gonna need you to buy up that deagle, and give the subscribe button just one tap, thank you very much.
Without further or do, here are the Top 10 One Deags in CS:GO.
Kicking off our list is Coldzera at IEM Oakland 2016
Cold caught an attacking RPK with the
deag before showing a falling Shox
why he’s one of the best players in the world.
(Casting)
At number nine, we've got NiKo’s 3k against G2 at Dreamhack Cluj-Napoca 2015.
The Bosnian superstar used his trusty deag to completely shut down an onslaught of G2 players.
(Casting)
Coming in at number eight, is Autimatic versus compLexity at DreamHack Montreal 2017.
Autimatic showed off his stealth skills while taking A site, catching two off-guard CTs with one deag.
He followed that up by out aiming two more compLexity  players, grabbing himself four kills with only five shots.
(Casting)
Next up is s1mple’s rotate at ESL One New York.
S1mple surgically 1v1’d four Virtus.pro players to completely deflate their potential comeback.
(Casting)
Coming in at number six, another Autimatic clip, this time against Gambit.
The C9 player once again showed off some slick deags, dismantling the CIS team's buy round at
DreamHack Open Winter 2016.
(Casting)
Coming in at number five, Kjaerbye’s Deagle clutch against Na`Vi.
Just when Natus Vincere thought they could really pull away with the game, in comes Kjaerbye with the deagle.
The Astralis player landed three one deags in a row, and proceeded to finish off Edward with the
headshot, securing the second round win in the last eleven.
(Casting)
At number four we’ve got Taco dismantling Astralis’ B push on Mirage.
The SK Gaming player EVICTED the Danes from apartments with his superintendent Mr. D. Eagle.
(Casting)
Coming in at number three we've got Dupreeh smothering FaZe Clan
at the IEM Katowice 2017 Grand Finals.
Dupreeh completely derailed FaZe, taking on the whole team by himself with nothing but a trusty deagle.
(Casting)
The runner-up on our list goes to NiKo once again, against Titan at ESL Pro League.
The French team lined up for NiKo as he single handedly dropped the entire squad as they ran up highway
to their deaths.
(Casting)
Capping off our list is Happy’s Deagle ace.
What is there left to say about this incredible play?
We all know it, we all love it.
It’s Happy single handedly destroying TSM.
(Casting)
Alright guys that’s our list.
Now we know there are a lot of one deags out there, but those were the ten we thought were the spiciest.
If you've got an idea for a Top 10 list you'd like to see us do next time,
let us know in the comment section below.